the ability to adjust is the entire game
I'm so proud that I changed my mind
every day my ability to only be
comfortable in massive chaos has been my
biggest asset as an entrepreneur you
need to do you it's so damn important
to stick to like your DNA recognize that
you need to surround yourself whether
it's your co-founder or whether it's the
people that work for you all I do is
hire the people that are the opposite of
me that bring the other value that bring
me the ability to remember that meeting
was about and go make sure it happens I
delegate everything that I think is not
the single most important things in the
world and then I micromanage the things
that I think are the most important
things in the world luckily I don't
think most things matter so I don't
think I'm any different than anybody
else I actually think everybody is a
delegator and a micromanager I just
think that my radar of what's important
is different the difference is I don't
think most things matter like I don't
think like one client that's gonna put
us out of it like I don't think one
employees gonna kill our atmosphere like
like like I I don't think a lot of
things matter I don't think like crud
like a misspelling in a deck is
something that really matters you just
watched two amazing clips from Gary
Vaynerchuk take the next three minutes
to sit quietly and think about how you
can apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]